Okay.
And this video will introduce the idea
of parameters sharing and convolutional
neural networks.
Yes.
So we've seen before the,
uh,
idea of local connectivity that
convolutional neural networks a leverage.
And now we're ready to talk about the,
uh,
an additional idea of parameter
sharing across hidden units.
Yeah.
All right.
So this second idea that we're adding
on top of local connectivity is that,
uh, we will be sharing the parameters.
So the way that connections,
the values of the weights
of the connections between
the hidden units and the
units and the layer below, uh,
between, uh, certain units.
Specifically what we'll do is
that we'll take all of our, uh,
hidden units in some given hidden there
and we will segment the hidden units
into different so-called feature maps.
The units in the feature map will actually
share their parameters. That is the,
uh,
value of the way that connection between
a hidden unit and it's receptive field.
Uh, it's receptive to input
from the previous layer, uh,
will be exactly the same. It will be the
same values have the same connections.
And, uh, now the hidden units
within a same feature map,
they will distinguish themselves by
being connected at a different position.
So a different receptive fields centered
at a different possession in the
previous layer. So, uh,
specifically, normally,
uh, okay. So if we have a hidden
layer with three feature maps,
one, two, and three, then say
for the first feature map,
all of these hidden units,
we'll be using the same
matrix of connections.
Uh, so for instance, decision unit, uh,
imagine there were two pixels here
than it would be, I would require a,
a matrix two by two,
uh,
specifying the connection
between a dissident unit and
each of the pixels within
the receptive fields.
And now say this hidden unit
connected with that, uh,
receptive field,
which to simplify things would be just
two by two would use the same matrix of
weighted connections to
compute it's pre activation.
And similarly for that in unit,
also within the feature map,
we'll assume that we will actually
have a receptive field at each possible
position, uh, within the image. Uh,
there are extensions of convolutional
neural networks that are consider having
skipping certain, uh, receptive fields.
But just to simplify the description,
always assume where, uh, connecting, uh,
a feature map to all possible
receptive fields within the image.
And so when this feature map within
this feature and when connect, uh,
computing the reactivation
of all hidden units,
what we'll do is we'll use the
same set of parameters, compute it.
And so that hidden layer with
multiply this weight here by December,
put less this weight here by this input,
does this weight here times disempowered
and plus this weight here at time,
this input.
And then this hidden unit here would
do a with compute this input here,
times this weight, this input
here at times this weight, uh,
with at times this way and this
input here times this week.
So really I want to emphasize
that we're using the same matrix,
the same set of parameters,
uh, for this, uh,
this hidden unit and this hidden here.
And now I'll say in
the second feature map,
it would be using a different matrix of
parameters. So it would have its own, uh,
it's own two by two matrix of parameters.
And then when it's computing, uh,
say this hidden Munis computing,
because activation based
on that receptive field,
instead of multiplying
the inputs by this matrix,
multiply its input by that matrix instead.
And then same thing for
the third feature map.
So I'll use the notation
Wij for refereeing to these
matrices of connection.
So the Matrix that connects the iff input
channel in the previous layer with DJF
feature map in the hidden
layer will be noted as w Ij.
So WIP is actually a matrix here.
And uh, so this, for
instance, would be w, uh,
say we have just one, a one channel
in the input when Dotson color,
imagine it was, uh, in gray.
So this would be w one,
one. This matrix here would be w one, two,
and then there'd be another matrix
here, presumably, uh, with, uh,
which would correspond to one three.
So
I didn't,
parameter sharing allows us to reduce the
number of parameters even more because
now the different hidden units connected
at different positions actually have
the same set of parameters that we all
need to have for each feature map to
store one matrix of connections.
And also it has the nice property that
effectively within one feature map will
be extracting the same feature,
but at every position in the input.
So say feature map
corresponded to a it filter.
If we were to visualize it that uh,
looked something like a positive weights
here and then some negative weights in
that region.
Now it would mean that we would take a,
we'll be extracting that feature,
which is essentially detecting whether
there is an edge at this particular
position within the receptive field will
be detecting that feature everywhere in
the input because we'll be
comparing that, uh, set of, uh,
that filters centrally that a set of
connections with that receptive field,
but also the same filter with
this other receptive feeling,
every receptive fields, uh, in the
image. And now maybe feature map too.
So, okay. So in feature map one,
we extracting the actual feature,
but everywhere. Whereas feature
map do might be extracting say, uh,
that feature. So more like a,
perhaps a, uh, uh, horizontal,
uh, uh, action. And
that's going like this.
And in feature map three could be
something different like a diagonal.
So, um, to describe this property,
that feature map one is
extracting the same feature. Uh,
it turns out we can say that the feature
map before to visualize it as an image
would, uh, correspond to tens
formation. That is equity variant.
That is if we, uh, once we, uh,
say we take this input image and we apply
a transformation like a translation,
well in the visualization
that feature map,
we'll actually see exactly
the same transformation.
That pattern of activations
will be translated based
on the same transformation
as the one we applied in
the original input. For that
reason, we'll say that, uh,
the, uh, feature map will be equivalent.
Yeah.
So putting the local connectivity and the
private or sharing, uh, ideas together,
uh, then it means that we computing these
feature maps and these feature maps,
actually the computation
of these feature maps, uh,
actually corresponds to a
computing aid discreet convolution,
which is a notion taken
from signal processing.
This asterisk symbol is the
symbol for that operation.
And so computing the feature maps,
which are the pre activations for
the hidden layer, will correspond to,
uh,
doing a discrete convolution with a
channel from the previous layer using a
kernel matrix,
which we note that Ski Ij where I is the,
uh, uh, index of the
channel, the previous layer,
and Jay's the index of
the feature map again.
And that kernel is computed from
the, uh, hidden weights matrix.
W Ij, and specifically I'll
just correspond to a, uh,
Wij, but where we flipped the rows
and the columns in that Matrix.
So in the next videos,
I'll talk more precisely about what
we mean by discreet contribution.
For those that are not familiar
with what it is, but, uh,
just ignore that. For now, it means
that we're ready to look at, uh,
what would happen if we were to
compute the activation of hidden layer.
So, um, uh,
specifically I'm using here the notation
from this paper by Jared at all from
Nyu. And, um, so if we call x,
I d I have input channel from
the previous there, Kay. I,
Jay is going to be this
convolution kernel,
which is a function of
the weight matrix and a,
and so we essentially
consistently information about
the connections between the
IOC channel of input,
uh, and the GF feature.
They'll also introduce,
uh, these, uh, GJS here,
which are learned scaling factors.
And uh,
in their papers they note as Yj,
uh, the value of the activation,
that hidden layer.
Uh,
and so what they considered in that
paper for how they would compute the
activation of fit and layer is that they
would compute the pre activations using
a compilation from each of the IMF
input channel to Djf a feature map,
and then they would some across
the, uh, input channels. So for,
we compute the P activations coming from
each input channel that we sum all the
p activations, then you
apply some nonlinearity in
their paper, they chose 10 h,
but we could have used something else.
And they also decided to introduce this,
uh, a Gj learn factor, which, uh,
just in general for commercial neural
network is not something that's necessary,
but that's something they
decided to introduce.
And a that will correspond to Yj j which
is the activation a corresponding to
the JFF feature maps. So we
will have a j here will, uh,
be from one to the number of feature
map to want to have in our hidden layer.
And so each why Jay is one
of these feature maths, but
after the nonlinearity, uh,
such as the Tan h or the sigmoid,
a nonlinearity or any other nonlinearity
we've seen in regular people or neural
networks. So are, we could have
decided to introduce a bias here. Uh,
so we could have added a bias. A, a, B,
a j would have a separate bias in a
unique bias shared by all units across the
feature map. That's another variation.
So if you look at the literature,
there will be variations, uh, with
respect to this particular equation.
But the general idea remains the same.
We're computing feature maps and
often these feature maps are, uh,
we then apply a non linearity on it,
like a sigmoid or a talent or a
rectified linear activation function.
So in the next video,
I'll talk about this discrete convolution,
which is going to be,
this procedure will actually involve a
invoked when we're computing the feature
maps.
And it's actually important because there
are very efficient softwares that were
written for performing this
convolution very efficiently.
We'll be able to leverage
that, uh, when we computed,
we're doing for propagation and
the compulsion or a neural network.
And also it's important because
it makes it explicit. Now,
what's the convolutional a word when
we're talking about what we say that these
networks are convolutional.